♪ ♪
>> Juan: WELCOME BACK.
MANY ON THE LEFT ARE NOT HAPPY
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP’S PLAN TO
PUT A 60 DAY PAUSE ON LEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
CLAIMING THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
JUST PLAYING POLITICS, AND THAT
THE MOVIE IS DANGEROUS.
BUT TRUMP SAYS HE IS DOING IT TO
HELP THE ECONOMY.
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
NANCY PELOSI SUGGESTING THE
MOVIE IS ABOUT DIVERTING
ATTENTION.
>> HE IS A POOR LEADER.
HE IGNORES HIS OWN
RESPONSIBILITY.
AND ASSIGNS BLAME, INSTEAD OF
TAKING RESPONSIBILITY.
PAYING ATTENTION TO SCIENCE.
RECOGNIZING THE WORD AND ROLE OF
GOVERNMENT IN ALL OF THIS TO GET
THE JOB DONE FOR THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
AND SO HE HAS ENGAGED IN
DISTRACTIONS LIKE IMMIGRATION.
DISTRACTIONS LIKE SUPPORTING
PEOPLE IN THE STREET.
THEY ARE ALL DISTRACTIONS AWAY
FROM THE KNOWN FACT THAT HE HAS
A TOTAL FAILURE WHEN IT COMES TO
TESTING.
>> Juan: AND FORMER
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATE
BETO O’ROURKE HAD THIS ANGRY
RESPONSE.
"WHO THE BLANK DO YOU THINK IS
WORKING ON THE FARMS AND THE
SEED LOTS IN THE PACKING HOUSES
AND PROCESSING PLANTS AT A TIME
WHERE WE ARE STRUGGLING TO FEED
OURSELVES, WHO IS IN THE KITCHEN
PUSHED MARK WHO IS PICKING AND
PREPARING AND SERVING THE FOOD
WE EAT AND CLEANING UP AFTER?"
GREG, I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU ARE ALWAYS
ATTENTIVE TO HOW THESE POLITICAL
THINGS WORK.
I THOUGHT AHEAD, AND I WONDER IF
THE PRESIDENT IS BATING HIS
CRITICS ON THE LEFT?
BECAUSE HE MAKES A BOLD
STATEMENT ABOUT SHUTTING DOWN
IMMIGRATION, BUT THEN WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE DETAILS, THE DETAILS
SAY, JUST SUSPENDING FOR PEOPLE
WHO ARE EVEN APPLYING FOR
PERMANENT GREEN CARDS FOR 60
DAYS.
AND THERE IS AN EXCEPTION, THERE
IS AN EXCEPTION FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THE WORKER INDUSTRY.
SO IT’S NOT THAT HUGE OF A
CHANGE FROM WHERE WE ARE RIGHT
NOW.
>> Greg: IT’S NOT TOO BAD.
BUT I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT THAT
HE KNOWS HOW THE LEFT REACTS,
RIGHT.
IF TRUMP CURED CANCER, THE
NEW YORK HEADLINE WOULD READ
"TRUMP CURES CANCER, A AN
ILLNESS AMONG WHITE
NATIONALISTS."
AND IT IS FUNNY WHEN YOU CALL
SOMETHING RACIST WHEN IT
BENEFITS MINORITIES JOB WISE.
SO HE IS CUTTING IT PRETTY
SMART.
AND HE HAS KIND OF PUT BIDEN IN
A BOX ON THIS ONE, BECAUSE HOW
IS BIDEN GOING TO RESPOND?
HE CALLED IT RACIST WHEN HE SHUT
DOWN TRAVEL, SO WHAT IS HE GOING
TO DO NOW?
BECAUSE THEN HE HAD TO CHANGE
HIS MIND.
SO IT IS EXACTLY WHAT YOU SAID.
IT IS A MODERATE RESPONSE, AND
IT IS A SMART RESPONSE.
YOU DON’T ALLOW WALL CONS IF ALL
THE POSITIONS ON YOUR TEAM CAN
BE FULFILLED BY YOUR PLAYERS.
SO WE DON’T NEED WALL CONS RIGHT
NOW.
A BASEBALL ANALOGY.
>> Juan: JESSE,
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
I HEARD YOU.
OKAY.
PUT ME IN, COACH.
JESSE, "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL"
CALLED THIS MOVE BY THE
PRESIDENT ON IMMIGRATION
SUSPENSION A POLITICAL
DISTRACTION.
AND THEY POINTED OUT THAT BEFORE
THE CORONAVIRUS WE HAD SOME
HISTORIC LOW UNEMPLOYMENT.
WHILE IF ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS OR
ANY IMMIGRANT WAS TAKING AWAY
JOBS, HOW IS IT THAT SO MANY
JOBS WERE OPEN SO MANY WEEKS AGO
>> Jesse: ARE YOU KIDDING ME,
JUAN, 21 MILLION AMERICANS JUST
LOST THEIR JOBS IN FOUR WEEKS.
SO WHEN THE ECONOMY COMES BACK,
YOU WANT AMERICANS FIRST IN
LINE.
I GUESS THESE LEFTISTS WANT
AMERICANS SECOND IN LINE BEHIND
FOREIGN NATIONALS.
IT MAKES NO SENSE TO ME.
LET’S JUST TAKE NANCY PELOSI FOR
A SECOND PERCH HE MUST HAVE A
BRAIN FREEZE FROM ALL OF THAT
PRICEY ICE CREAM, BECAUSE
SCIENCE HAS PROVEN EVERY SINGLE
DECISION HERE.
SCIENCE WAS THE ONE THAT SHUT
DOWN TRAVEL FROM CHINA AND
EUROPE, SCIENCE WAS THE THING
THAT SHUT DOWN THE U.S. ECONOMY.
IF SHE THINKS DONALD TRUMP SHUT
DOWN THE GREATEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD, AN ECONOMY THAT WAS GOING
TO WIN HIM REELECTION BECAUSE OF
POLITICS, THEN DONALD TRUMP MUST
BE THE DUMBEST POLITICIAN IN
AMERICA BESIDES BETO ROURKE.
BECAUSE HERE’S THE SITUATION,
NANCY, WHO IS LIVING IN A
QUARANTINE IN HER MANSION
OVERLOOKING THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAY, WHEN SHE RIGHT NOW, WHAT
SHE OPEN HER DOOR TO A STRANGER,
A FOREIGN NATIONAL WHO SHE DOES
NOT KNOW WHERE THEY CAME FROM,
IF THEY HAD BEEN QUARANTINE, IF
THEY HAD BEEN TESTED?
NO.
WHY, NANCE, BECAUSE SCIENCE.
SO WHY SHOULD AMERICA DO THAT
RIGHT NOW?
AND I SAID, ECONOMICS.
ECONOMICS 101.
AND IF THEY WANT TO RUN ON OPEN
BORDERS AND FOREIGN LABOR, BE MY
GUEST.
SHE WILL LOSE HER GAVEL, JUST
LIKE SHE IS LOSING HER MIND.
>> Juan: WELL, I WAS TALKING
ABOUT "THE WALL STREET JOURNAL,"
WHICH IS A PRETTY CONSERVATIVE
EDITORIAL PAGE.
AND DANA, HERE’S WHAT "THE
JOURNAL" SAID.
THE ECONOMIC EVIDENCE POINTS TO
EMIGRATION COVERING RECOVERY,
HELPING WITH GROWTH.
AND OTHERS HAVE POINTED OUT THAT
IT IS SOMETHING LIKE 60% OF OUR
DOCTORS AND HEALTH CARE WORKERS
THAT ARE IMMIGRANTS.
>> Dana: AND THAT’S WHY I
THINK, HE IS VAGUE PURPOSEFULLY
WHEN HE DOES THE INITIAL TWEET,
BUT WHEN YOU GET TO THE END, YOU
FIND OUT THAT IT IS ACTUALLY A
VERY, I WOULD NOT SAY MODERATE,
I WOULD SAY MILD TO HAVE A PAUSE
FOR 60 DAYS, AND CARVE OUT FOR
FARM WORKERS HEALTH CARE
WORKERS, PROBABLY AT THE END OF
THIS IT WILL BE ENGINEERS AND
ET CETERA, BECAUSE IT IS TRUE,
WE KNOW THAT AMERICA IS FUELED
BY ENTREPRENEURSHIP, AND A LOT
OF THOSE ENTREPRENEURS ARE
IMMIGRANTS.
WE HAVE THAT IN OUR OWN FAMILIES
HISTORY ON THIS SHOW.
SO I THINK YOU FOOL ME ONCE WHEN
YOU REACT SO AGGRESSIVELY, ONE
OF THE PRESIDENT’S BIG TWEETS.
AND COMMUNICATION STYLE, YOU
WAIT AND YOU FIND OUT THAT THE
POLICY IS REALLY NOT THAT
DIFFERENT.
AND SO, IF YOU ARE JOE BIDEN,
YOU REALLY ARE IN A BOX.
BECAUSE IF YOU REACT TO THE
INITIAL TWEET AND YOU HAVE THAT,
YOU’RE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY FOR
UNTIL THE ELECTION AND THEN YOU
GET TO THE POLICY AND YOU ARE
LIKE, OH, I ACTUALLY AGREE WITH
THAT.
>> Juan: YES, IT IS KIND OF
CURIOUS.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT
IMMIGRATION IS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE RESPONSE OF THE VIRUS, CAN
YOU AGREE TO THAT MUCH?
>> Judge Jeanine: I DON’T KNOW
IF WE KNOW ENOUGH, ARE WE
RELYING ON STUDIES AND SCIENCE,
AND I DON’T THINK ANYBODY IS
CAPABLE OF ANSWERING THAT.
BUT I THINK THE IMPORTANT POINT
IS THAT WHEN THE ECONOMY DOES
COME BACK, A LOT OF THESE
BUSINESSES, YOU KNOW, THE
22 MILLION AMERICANS WHO ARE OUT
OF WORK AND I’M SURE IT’S GOING
UP AGAIN AT THE END OF THE WEEK,
THEY ARE NOT GOING TO HAVE A
BUSINESS TO GO BACK TO YOU.
AND THAT IT’S BETWEEN THEM AND
SOMEONE COMING IN FROM ANOTHER
COUNTRY TO GET THAT JOB.
WHATEVER THAT NUMBER IS, HOWEVER
SMALL PEOPLE MAY THINK THAT THIS
CHANGE IS ACCORDING TO THE
PRESIDENTS ORDER HERE IS
SIGNIFICANT TO AMERICAN
FAMILIES.
AND IN THE END, THAT IS, HE IS
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES FOR AMERICANS.
AND THE MORE THAT JOE BIDEN
STARTS TALKING ABOUT
IMMIGRATION, THE MORE THAT HE
GOES DOWN INTO THE RABBIT HOLE,
BECAUSE HE HAS TO REMEMBER, HE
IS RUNNING TO BE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES, NO OTHER
COUNTRY, AND IT’S GOING TO BITE